this video is sponsored by Teemu do you
like things you know stuff you like
buying stuff and things online well I'm
sure you've heard of Teemu by now but
just in case you haven't they're an
online retailer that allows customers to
buy items with massive discounts
discounts that are so massive that a lot
of people find them kind of hard to
believe but I went on a mini shopping
spree and chose several items from their
store like this full set of every Zelda
NFC card available and this breath of
the wild themed LED light and this
PlayStation LED light and this standing
room light and several others and I
received each and every one of them in
amazing quality the cards feel great and
all work as they should the lights are
bright and beautiful and ready to be
hung on my wall and the room light works
so well and can dim or switch modes
remotely which is great because I don't
like to get up more than I absolutely
have to they're constantly running
sitewide sales with discounts of up to
90% and get this everything comes with
free shipping and a 90day return policy
and if you click the link in the
description below or type in my code DK
n 9526 in the teu search bar you can
claim a limited edition $100 coupon
bundle and if and when you use all of
those coupons you can claim a Nintendo
switch for a discount at $259 and now on
to the
video if I started writing a book series
called The Tale of let's call it the
tale of
Zebulon and I wrote one book and then I
wrote another and called it the tale of
Zebulon 2 and then I wrote another and
then another and then another and
they're all called The Tale of Zebulon
something 3 4 five the tale of Zebulon
essence of the Void whatever and within
those books I had references to the
other books that came before it or maybe
hints about books that might come in the
future you look me in the eyes and tell
me that you would not think those books
are connected and whose fault is that it
would be mine the authors right so here
we are again I know I keep making these
videos this is the third one of these
ramble rant type videos and after I went
live with those videos it really opened
the door for a lot of commenters to come
at me with a lot of arguments and I'm I
am a a Creator but I'm also a person you
may have noticed so I would like the
chance to defend myself a lot of people
watching right now and even if this
isn't you watching then I'll tell you
that these people exist a lot of fans of
many franchises but specifically for
this case fans of the Zelda franchise
get upset at people for being upset with
Nintendo for the way that they've
handled the lore in recent games and
that's fair it's fair to have differing
opinions it's fair to care more about
one thing or less about another there's
no problem with that I take issue though
with the argument that specifically
Nintendo never cared about the timeline
or never cared about the lore in their
Zelda games and that that was entirely
on us the fans back in the day
theorizing and and whatever it made we
forced Nintendo to create a timeline
where they never wanted to do it but we
held a gun to their heads and said you
connect these games or else we're not
buying your games anymore or whatever
and that's what I'd like to debunk in
this video and a couple disclaimers
number one as always I am a rambler
apologies in advance and number two
there will be spoilers in this video
probably maybe maybe not but here's a
theoretical spoiler warning for you
you're welcome so really this argument
that's been brought up about Nintendo
not caring about the Zelda Timeline is
not a new one it's been there for the
entire time that my channel has been a
thing really I I I've seen these on
every timeline video I make or every
time that I even remotely criticize the
lore in the Zelda franchise I see these
comments just popping up but recently
they've been popping up all over the
place not just because of the ramble
videos that I uploaded but also because
there was a recent interview another one
that came out with the same people anuma
the producer of The Legend of Zelda
series and Fuji Bashi the director of
both breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom it's a new interview with game
inform and it's a really cool interview
they're just asking about you know what
they're going to do with the future of
the franchise they actually say
something really cool in the interview
they say that Aluma says that he
refrains from commenting on a an aine of
time remake uh which could mean that
it's just such a tired subject he
doesn't want to talk about it or
obviously the elephant in the room is it
could mean that they are working on an a
of time remake which
would probably effectively break the
gaming world for a little bit but what I
want to focus on is let me find it real
quick they were asked pretty directly
about the timeline here it is when
you're developing a new Zelda title
obviously your primary focus is on core
gameplay but the timeline placement
discussion has become more important and
prevalent among the fans of the series
how much consideration and importance
does the development team put into those
discussions so clearly there have been
enough of us I guess at this point
talking about the timeline and talking
about the lore that even places like
Game Informer have taken notied and fuju
bash's answer is as follows as you
mentioned we realized that fans have a
great time theorizing and enjoy thinking
about where things fit on the timeline
cheers to that that's something that
that the development team recognizes and
it considers but to an extent and I say
to an extent because if we get too into
the weeds or too detailed in that
placement it results in kind of creating
restraints for our creativity the
process of creating new ideas becomes
restricted because we're so tied up and
trying to make this fit into a very
specific spot in the timeline we do
consider it but not to an ENT where we
feel that our development process feels
restricted or
constrained there you have it folks
right off the bat we've got the answer
from the word of God Nintendo themselves
saying that Nintendo does not
necessarily care about the timeline
anymore and that much I agree with when
Link's Awakening came out the the Remake
it swapped its positioning on the
official Canon timeline from after the
Oracle games to before if I remember
correctly so that's actually something
that I agree age with but what I take
issue with is the notion that they never
cared about the timeline or that it's
the fans fault for making the timeline a
thing in the first place in the first
place if you are the kind of fan who
says that Nintendo never cared about the
Zelda Timeline honestly you are kind of
ousting yourself a little bit as either
a fan who hasn't been here for all that
long or a fan who has been here but
hasn't really been paying attention from
the get-go the first Legend of Zelda
was much more detailed with its
storytelling than a game it's its sister
game of Super Mario or Donkey Kong as it
originally was called obviously in
Donkey Kong Mario formerly known as
Jumpman just scales a tower and saves
the girl from a big monkey in The Legend
of Zelda Link has to venture around and
find secret caves and has to find
upgrades to weapons and and other items
to use and battle all sorts of different
kinds of monsters and go through
dungeons in whatever order he feels like
and then retrieve the Triforce and
battle against a giant Pigman demon and
then save the princess it has a story in
its loading screen and if you have a
Nintendo switch with the Nintendo switch
Online subscription fire up your NES
launch The Legend of Zelda and just wait
for the loading screen to start playing
it reveals a story to you so right off
the bat the Legend of Zelda wanted to
tackle a more fantasy setting with a
story Zelda 2 came out and it was a
sequel to The Legend of Zelda a sequel
to a game is a game that comes after a
game that's a timeline and really the
timeline of Zelda games was all centered
around Ganon back in the day the first
Legend of Zelda dealt with defeating
Ganon Legend of Zelda 2 or I'm sorry
just Zelda 2 The Adventure of Link dealt
with preventing his resurrection A Link
to the Past was the first Zelda game
where they decided they were going to do
kind of a prequel because a link to the
past is kind of a origin story for Ganon
it explains where Ganon came from in the
Manu that had never been done before
that point you even read that his real
life human name used to be Ganon Dwarf
dragmire so the fact that there was a
same the same villain who had become
this demonic two-legged Pig demon who
you can read used to be human in the
booklet for the game meant that it was
really supposed to be a prequel and
people put those dots together they
connected those dots Link's Awakening
came out which was the same kind of
thing that Zelda 2 was to the original
Legend of Zelda Link's Awakening was a
sequel to A Link to the Past it was that
link from that game continuing his
Adventure then aine of time came out and
we got a prequel to A Link to the Past
because now we got to see Ganondorf
dragmire and then we legitimately get to
see Ganondorf become Ganon and if you're
following me so far it's really not that
hard to explain the games keep coming
out in their kind of prequels the the
original Legend of Zelda was always
supposed to be kind of the most
futuristic one they kept coming out
explaining the history of Ganon in some
other way fans connected the dots
because there were dots to be connected
placed there by Nintendo but then as you
know aine of time is where things got
kind of funky because at the end of
ocarine of time the timeline splits and
they always knew the timeline was going
to split and we have two evidences for
that one wind waker the beginning of
Wind Waker directly explains link
popping into that timeline when he drew
the master sword an a of time and popped
into the adult timeline and then popping
out of it after he defeats Ganon that is
directly explained in the intro segment
of the Wind Waker and the second thing I
wanted to talk about were the several
different interviews from the early 2000
late
1990s where mamoto and anuma both talked
directly about the Zelda timeline in
1999 mamoto was asked by an interviewer
that and this interview was included in
apparently the original aine of time
booklet he was asked uh before it was
released Nintendo announced that this
new Nintendo 64 Zelda could unlock the
mysteries of the entire Zelda story
could you tell us about that in your
your own words to which mamoto responded
maybe Mysteries was a bit of an
exaggeration but you do learn the story
of where the Triforce came from and it
is meant to be episode one of the Zelda
Saga the basic ORD is Ocarina then the
original Legend of Zelda followed be by
a link to the past which obviously is
not really how the Legend of Zelda
Timeline as we know it today is laid out
but back in the day that was Moto's
understanding in the same interview he
goes on to say that on the importance of
like story and continu between the games
right now our highest priority is to
create an interesting game first and
foremost sometimes that means not
worrying about the joints not lining up
perfectly which is inevitable anyway
excluding really obvious big breaks in
continuity we ignore the little
inconsistencies this interview explains
both points it explains that one it's
true mamoto and Co were not super super
concerned about making sure everything
lined up however he was concerned with
making things line up up in the big
picture way in the big timeline way he
goes on to say for that reason I've
often been accused of not caring about
the story but when I consider the medium
of video games above intro series
continuity it's far more important to me
that the player is left with a
satisfying aftertaste once the
experience is over and only to that
extent do I care about continuity in
that huge breaks with Canon or previous
games would make players feel betrayed
and we don't want that as you can see he
directly talks about the fact that a lot
of people do accuse him for not caring
about the story and only caring about
experience to which he responded
essentially I mean kind of mostly but
not entirely He does care about
experience first and foremost and he's a
freaking Visionary he came up with Mario
he came up with Zelda we need people who
think about experiences first and
foremost obviously but part of that
experience to him as you just heard is
Canon continuity he says once again huge
breaks with Canon or previous games
would make players feel betrayed and we
don't want that what I'm trying to say
is that Nintendo themselves created the
timeline that's all I'm trying to prove
here I'm not I it's both right of course
a lot of people were clamoring to figure
out the secrets of the timeline back in
1997 when they were giving commercials
for aine of time that's when they said
unravel the mysteries of the Zelda
franchise excuse me and there were only
four games out before then and they were
all pretty easy to understand as far as
fitting
in between one another or whatever and
they did make the choice to name each of
them Zelda games so they knew they knew
that people were going to be trying to
connect them one to another they are the
ones who created that situation and I
know I keep I keep repeating this I feel
like I've repeated that 20 times but I'm
just I'm trying to say it to where you
will hear me Nintendo created the
timeline they wanted to now they did not
want to put all that much of an effort
into making it consistent 100% me me
personally this is where I kind of don't
understand what's up with that a little
bit because to me I feel like those
don't have to be two
separate Concepts you don't have to only
focus on experience of a game or
whatever without focusing on the story
and the lore whatever or vice versa you
don't only have to focus on the story
and the lore and then like you just have
a boring game that doesn't matter or
whatever the argument that that was
brought up in the recent 2023 interview
with anuma and fuu bayashi and Game
Informer that
Nintendo would be constricting their
creativity restricting it within the
timeline if they focused on it too much
is I think I think a little flawed
because if you think about it is the
Legend of Zelda not already a
constriction their universe that they
created is that not already a
constriction the fact that they will not
make Zelda playable after Decades of
people asking for it is that not already
a constriction that they are refusing to
push through they will not give up the
balance of Link and Zelda and evil the
balance of the three forces is that not
a restriction but within that
restriction they've been able to come up
with some pretty damn Creative Concepts
I mean Zelda herself has been how many
different things across the franchise
Sheik Tetra
hilia and then obviously all the unique
things that happened with her breath of
the wild and tears of the Kingdom all
within the Restriction of no playable
Zelda and Zelda not being an immediate
part of the story the whole time and
playing through large portions of the
game without her they can focus on
working within restrictions and working
within preset patterns it just has to be
one that they want to focus on and for
some reason they don't want to focus on
the timeline and if I may critique
Nintendo just a little bit here I think
that's a little illogical or not
illogical but a little uninspired
because listen if you give an artist a
blank canvas to work with or if you give
a writer a new franchise to work with
whatever is written whatever is drawn
whatever is painted whatever colors they
use or don't use whatever all of it is
100% creative is it not because there
was nothing there before however if you
introduce restraints and restrictions
and then give someone the Liberty to
create something B B off of that in my
opinion that's what inspires true
creativity and to be honest with you I
also find it a little hard to believe
that it is just that difficult it's just
that difficult to write a story within
the constraints of the universe that
you've already created I mean Middle
Earth does it pretty well Star Wars well
okay maybe not Star Wars but Metroid the
Metroid franchise does it really well
it's not impossible you can create one
continuous story honestly the Zelda
franchise has the perfect setup for it
they just snap their fingers and 100 to
10,000 plus years will just evaporate in
between games you can do so many
different things with that you can leave
Hyrule go to a different land I don't
even have time to get into the thousands
of fresh creative ideas that can be
implemented while into the Zelda
franchise while working within the
constraints of the established lore and
the established universe so to me that's
a choice from Nintendo that I don't
necessar
understand but I digress just to recap
this whole all of my rambling has really
made two major points one Nintendo did
create the timeline whether or not it
was from goting from fans or whatever
Nintendo created the timeline and two
Nintendo already restricts themselves in
other ways just not with the timeline
apparently and honestly I don't think
the timeline was all that difficult to
understand initially there were only
supposed to be two timeline splits off
of aine of time with Ganon being created
and then as mamoto explained with it
then going on to lead into the original
Legend of Zelda and then Zelda 2 and
then a link to the past and then Link's
Awakening and that's that's pretty easy
to understand and even once Majora's
maskk came out things were still pretty
easy to understand because there was a
split at the end of acarine of time into
the child and adult timelines But as
time went on they didn't want to leave
Ganon and Ganon Dwarf as villains behind
and they kept making games with him as
the villain which became harder and
harder to interpret into this timeline
that at one point was pretty easy to
understand and for the games that were
the most difficult to understand like a
link to the past especially since Ganon
is said to or is shown to be defeated at
the end of arine of time in both
timelines once they placed a link to the
past in the Fallen timeline and then all
of the other games that they couldn't
explain their timeline placement also in
the Fallen timeline I think that's where
all of the tension started to come from
because the Fallen timeline doesn't make
sense and I've Ted talked about this
before adult timeline child timeline
those are legitimate splits that you can
understand because of the end of acarine
of time but the Fallen timeline is
another reality it's the reality where
link dies at the end of aine of time
he's not able to defeat Ganon or Ganon
dworf depending on which one he's
fighting at the time obviously if you
have beaten aine of time then that is
not canon but the fact that the Fallen
timeline exists means that it is Canon
so that's why things started to get I
feel a little a little icky and for a
lot of people who saw that and saw that
it didn't really make sense they started
to be much more vocal about the fact
that oh it's the fans fault it's not
Nintendo's fault Nintendo would never
make a mistake like that it's the fans
fault the fans are the ones who created
the timeline in the first place and the
fans are the ones who are now messing it
up and that is why I made this entire
freaking video just to prove two people
once and for all to point back to this
video whenever these comments inevitably
come up in the future that yes fans were
excited about the timeline and
connecting the dots in between games
because there were dots to be connected
and because there was a timeline as
proven in the 9s from mamoto but fans
are not the ones who messed it up I
think the fatal error was making the
decision to include a timeline in The
Legend of Zelda but not actually focus
on it and going forward for game
franchises I think that if you're going
to create lore I think that you need to
make a decision off the bat if you're
going to pay pention to that lore
because if you're not going to why even
make a sequel in the same game series
just make a new franchise it's been
nearly 40 years I don't think they're
ever going to drop the name The Legend
of Zelda but I think that they should
drop the timeline personally I think
they should drop the Continuum I think
that they should put their money where
their mouths are because in that in the
game inform forer interview yeah see in
in this interview they were asked uh
does the Hy rro we saw in the flashback
scenes and tears of the Kingdom predate
Skyward Sword or does it come after the
other games in the timeline and this is
one of the most infamous answers that
they they gave in this entire interview
Fuji bayashi says obviously there's
something a bit clearer in our minds but
of course it could be that we're wrong
as well I kind of want toose the idea
that like in real life history you
defined by the artifacts and by the data
that you currently have and I wasn't
aware that you know real life history is
just so malleable but apparently it is
so within what we have there might be a
correct answer but it could be a
different answer so I guess my answer
would be that it could be both both
could be correct and anuma chimed in and
said I mean the Legend of Zelda a series
of games that focuses on on puzzle
solving so this is just another sort of
puzzle that the users will have to see
if they can solve and think about for
people who are Die Hard fans of the lore
that might be a frustrating answer
because basically they threw their hands
in the air and went I don't know doesn't
really matter it's up to people to think
about but honestly I I'm not mad about
that because I that's what I'm saying
should happen drop the timeline let let
the fans who who care about the timeline
come up with the timeline and work with
it and and like just have like a fan a
fan in Timeline because at this point
the dozens of timeline theories out
there work a lot better than what is
Canon especially since it switches
around and especially since the very
creators of the series and developers of
the series themselves say really it's up
to the fans to interpret how they want
so I think they should put their money
where their mouth is and do that drop
the Canon timeline stop these arguments
between or among fans about whether or
not Nintendo cared about it in the first
place place or whatever and just let us
ride it
ourselves so anyway that's it I just
wanted to make the final of these ramble
Trilogy videos about responding to what
began with tears of the Kingdom
criticism and what is now ending with
timeline criticism again I would like to
reiterate I love the Legend of Zelda as
a franchise it is my favorite gaming
franchise to date I love breath of the
wild I really liked tears of the Kingdom
nothing wrong with loving either of
those games or or not loving the
franchise as whole there's nothing wrong
with whatever opinion you have right now
and there's nothing wrong with my
opinion but I just wanted to set the
record straight so I made this video but
of course as I'm ending I want to just
ask you people what do you think should
happen with the Zelda Timeline do you
think that it needs to be redone by
Nintendo just reoriented with official
placements for breath of the wild and
tears of the Kingdom finally and maybe
even other non-canon games like the hyal
Warriors games placed on the timeline
finally or do you think that they should
do you agree with me and think that they
should release the Canon timeline back
to the fans put their money where their
mouth is like they say in interviews and
let us figure it out let me know in the
comments below I'm probably not going to
do another one of these ramble type
videos for a while unless there's a
topic that I feel passionate enough
about but if you're still watching thank
you so much for watching just like I've
done with the other two videos here's my
little test for you if you're still
watching say my favorite Zelda game is
and then with your Zelda your favorite
Zelda Zelda game in a comment below you
can also comment whatever else you want
under that but make that the first line
if you're still watching and I'll see
cuz I've been seeing I'll
know anyway that's all for this video
thank you guys so much for being here
leave a like on it if you enjoyed it or
if you just enjoyed seeing my face or if
you like The Legend of Zelda leave a
like for either of those And subscribe
if you haven't already for lots of
gaming lore to come that's all I've got
for this one so follow me on my socials
and that's about it this is banit
looking forward to seeing you next time
and signing out peace